what don't you get have you no self
esteem self regard self-respect where is
your dignity why would you stay in a job
where you're not wanted a job you took
under false pretences knowing you
wouldn't be able to do the complete job
and why do you continue to stay no one
elected you Jeff voted for you petition
to make sure you got the job you're
certainly not entitled to the job you
grovelled and begged for the job and out
of loyalty he gave it to you you're so
clueless you don't even know you're
being used you don't even know you're
nothing but a shill in fact the only
constituency that wants you is the deep
state that needs someone to protect
their flank from an investigation from
rod Rosenstein to James Comey John
Brennan James clapper Loretta Lynch
Peter struck Andrew McCabe the Clintons
Obama and on and on are you proud of
yourself
you've taken the blindfold off Lady
Justice and waited the scales in favor
of anyone who's a Democrat and refused
to do your job to prosecute corruption
by the Democrats now I know you spent 20
years in the Senate doing basically
nothing in 20 years you sponsored seven
bills that became law one of them the
James Madison commemoration Commission
of 2000 whatever the hell that was now
maybe your brain got juiced while you
enjoyed the fruits of the most exclusive
50 member club in America but why did
you really need or even deserve to be
Attorney General and so now you've
refused yourself in the 2016 Russian
election probe okay
but what's your excuse for not acting
like the AG can't you see what's going
on for all intents and purposes the
Russia collusion investigation is over
because there is no Russia collusion by
President Trump or his team hard as they
all tried to frame the president
unhinged conspiracy theory is dead
Muller's moved on from Russia to
obstruction and now to hookers [ __ ]
porn stars and campaign contributions
you want to talk campaign contributions
let's talk about the millions Hillary
funneled to the law firm that laundered
it through fusion GPS to create a false
document to calm the FISA Court to
surveil the campaign of the opposing
outsider candidate even a nonpartisan
government watchdog group filed a
complaint with the FEC in October of
2017 alleging Hillary and the DNC
violated that campaign finance law what
are you doing about that did she just go
scot-free again Jeff if you're not
corrupt and if the fix isn't in because
they've got something on you
then you've been duped can't you see the
damage to this country by this
fraudulent investigation that you
breathe life into by allowing them to
run amok can't you see from under your
desk that this nation is being torn
apart as they continue to promote their
lunacy the president against the
president that we elected Muller's
charge doesn't prevent you from
investigating other corruption how can
you possibly ignore the flow of hundreds
of millions of dollars in cash to the
Bill and Hillary corrupt foundation as
Russian sought fertile ground for their
uranium racketeering into the Clinton
bank account how can you ignore that
Hillary Clinton said American foreign
policy to coincide with the flow of
hundreds of millions of dollars to her
foundation and Bill was the bag man and
you know there's never been a real audit
how can you watch as Muller as he
desperately hands out immunity so he can
prosecute the man he's targeted for no
reason at all
while Comey and Lynch gave immunity like
candy and no one was ever brought before
a grand jury let alone prosecuted
Hillary Cheryl Mills uu mob at an
Anthony
Weiner Bryan Pagliano how do you justify
that Hilary got a heads up that she can
obstruct justice destroy evidence and
33,000 emails and put our classified
secrets at risk while a target in a tax
case years old has his door broken down
at 5:00 a.m. and he's then put in
solitary confinement 23 hours a day
before he is even tried even your best
friends Lindsey Graham and Chuck
Grassley have had it with you and are
ready to throw you under the bus grassy
sayin he could find the time to hold
hearings to replace you Lindsey's saying
you will very likely be replaced and the
vacancy Reform Act they can see were a
format look it up Jeff allows for the
appointment of a new Attorney General on
a temporary basis without Senate
confirmation so now Jeff isn't it grand
you tell the president that you are
standing for justice you're standing is
nothing more than a front a shill for a
corrupt deep State and you have the
nerve to talk about justice and all the
bad actors who desperately need you to
protect them from the sword of Damocles
are blowing smoke and telling you to
stay the course they're laughing at your
it is see idiocy because not only are
you allowing Muller and his band of
Trump hating Democrat lawyers to
continue their investigation in search
of a crime any crime into now the
president's business finances having
nothing to do with Russia are you proud
of yourself well I am the AG the actions
of the Department of Justice will not be
improperly influenced by political
considerations are you kidding all of
America knows the DOJ continues to be
influenced by politics that's why they
elected the outsider president they see
it every day when the DOJ and the FBI
smugly refused to respond
to congressional subpoenas and when
absolutely required they hand over
documents blackened out and unreadable
by the way Jeff if you and your pals
think you are getting to the president
think again this president can take the
shots he's done it his whole life never
underestimate him or his powers but you
need to do one of two things
resign immediately because you're not
wanted put on your big-boy pants and be
a real Attorney General and that's my
open if you like my opening statements
you'll love my new book New York Times
number-one bestseller
liars leakers and liberals the case
against the anti Trump conspiracy